as he arrived at the General Assembly
the world was watching for president
Trump's next to move on Iran the US has
been joined by the UK France and Germany
in holding Iran responsible for the
drone attacks on Saudi oil facilities
but the president who launched a policy
of maximum pressure on Tehran is still
for now talking about possible diplomacy
on Iran I think we're doing very well
let's see what happens with Iran but we
are we're in very strong position on
Iran and I think they'd like to do
something and I think would be a smart
thing for them if they do and of course
when he took to the podium inside the
general assembly hall
there was plenty of criticism of Iranian
policy but also another olive branch
America is ready to embrace friendship
with all who genuinely seek peace and
respect many of America's closest
friends today were once our greatest
foes the United States has never
believed in permanent enemies we want
partners not adversaries America knows
that well anyone can make war only the
most courageous can choose peace in the
speech there were also tough words for
China an effort perhaps to increase the
pressure on Beijing ahead of forthcoming
trade talks the American people are
absolutely committed to restoring
balance to our relationship with China
hopefully we can reach an agreement that
will be beneficial for both countries
but as I have made very clear I will not
accept a bad deal for the American
people when he spoke the UN
secretary-general raised concerns that
the war of words between China and the
US could develop into something much
more serious
I fear the possibility of a great
fracture the world splitting in two with
the two largest economies on earth
creating two separate and competing
world
which we their own dominant currency
trade and financial rules they are only
internet and artificial intelligence
capacities and their own zero-sum
geopolitical and military strategies
when he attended the official luncheon
with other world leaders and the
Secretary General President Trump
praised the United Nations that was in
contrast to a typical Trump speech which
promoted national sovereignty ahead of
multilateralism and slammed globalists
James BAE's al Jazeera at the United
Nations